okay ladies and gentlemen welcome good
evening
it is now two minutes past six and we
have gone live so
uh welcome my name is counselor peter
richards i will be chairing this
evening's
meeting before we go uh straight into
our applications just a bit of
housekeeping first of all
um i think everyone knows these rules
anyway but
phones if you could please either turn
them off or at the very least turn them
to silent i don't mind using them but as
long as they don't interfere with the
running of this meeting um we are being
recorded and live streamed so uh please
be aware of that
while we are going through matters and
listening to applications
um it is this is not
a public meeting it is a meeting with
some
public involvement so any speakers that
are registered to speak will be
permitted
too uh we'll give you your timings at
the right time and i'll call you forward
um please don't shout out from the uh uh
from the viewing gallery it will be only
those permitted to speak or register to
speak will be able to speak
um we obviously also have to manage
ourselves through covert um
so you'll see on the desktop speakers
when you're called to come up
um if you could please cleanse your
hands with the
sanitizer that is there if you wear your
masks on your way to the desk but when
you're sat down and even when you're sat
down in the gallery if you want to take
them off that's absolutely fine
once you're done with your speaking if
you could please take a wipe
and wipe the desk and also the
microphone and then clench your hands
again and make your way back that would
be
great okay some intros
to our team to my immediate right we
have and banks from committee services
to my immediate left we have ross
chambers our solicitor we also have our
planners neil hempstead uh joe brook
sarah chadwick stuart fleit and joining
us on teams is david pilcher
our highways expert we also have alice
cosner who is our planning manager for
this evening alex i believe you have a
statement to make
yes thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking
thank you very much indeed okay let's
dive straight into the list so apologies
please first of all
apologies from councillor adam and eden
marvelous thank you very much um can i
just say that again because my mic
wasn't on
didn't press hard enough sorry apologies
from councillors
adam and edin marvelous thank you very
much do we have any disclosures of
interest
please members council jennings first
okay
as in my past on the first application
two zero slash zero two seven four five
slash
ot in my capacity as a portfolio holder
i have attended a presentation from one
of the speakers jonathan thompson
uh regarding long marston airfield next
door
but i've not been involved in any
discussion on this application
and i'll therefore be approaching this
with an open mind and will be involved
in the debate
i have also received a number of emails
from
various are from a solicitor and various
others
relating to the
third application
thank you very much that is application
2100 561 very garages adjacent to lee
crescent i believe
and i have also received similar
correspondence i'm assuming it's the
same for everyone so we'll have a
blanket
uh disclosure for that similarly
for application three two eight six ful
that is land adjacent twenty two hundred
and one loxi road again i've received uh
a series of correspondence i can see a
lot of nodding so we'll have a blanket
disclosure that everyone has received
that
um i also have a couple disclosures
while i've got the microphone so uh on
the first one in my capacity as a
previous portfolio holder i also
have got to know jonathan but uh we have
not spoken about this and i come within
a completely open mind
um and the final application which is uh
the old butcher's shop in claverden that
is in my ward although i have made no
representation
and i've not registered to speak so i
will be maintaining my seat on
the uh committee um when we go through
that again with an open mind
do we have any other disclosures members
that haven't already been covered
please no jolly good okay let's move on
uh
minutes everyone happy with the minutes
i'll sign them afterwards if we are
quick show hands yes lots of nods that
looks unanimous to me
great okay let's move in then to our
first application which is application
twenty zero
two seven four five out uh it has been
presented
by our champion planner here
neil hempstead nail over to you
thank you chairman
the application site is shown on the
screen with the
with the black dot so it's immediately
adjacent to um to long marston airfield
and just to give a bit more context to
that this is the
the red outline for the application site
um probably points to note are the
nearest residential properties which are
referred to willow cottage
and the moats here this is the main site
where the built form will be
and this is the this is the access
this is long marston airfield which
members may be aware of permission for
400
dwellings has been granted and that has
that's currently being constructed on
site at the moment
so i'm conscious that the the red line
site is rather odd in terms of the
the access there so just just to give a
bit more context just to show how that's
going to fit in with the long marston
airfield in the first instance
this is the illustrative master plan for
the entire long marston sites
which is in the adopted spd
so the area that we are talking about is
is the corner here
so part of that is airfield house and
i've got another plan to show in a bit
more detail and
the rest of it is occupied by willow
cottage
just something to point out on here so
this is the main roundabout access which
is being constructed at the moment
i'll make reference to a primary school
site a community and employment hub
and the initial 400 which is in this
area
so the 400 has got permission at the
moment there's a current application in
which is being determined in respect of
the rest of the site
so just to go into a bit more detail and
i might zoom in at
this point um so we've got the 400
here which i said is currently being
constructed the third the front
properties are
and the roundabout access at the moment
um this is um
the application site in question for the
60 houses
and the reason why the access looked
slightly
strange in its arrangement is that it
fits in with the
long marston plan so effectively
following my cursor
that is the that's the access in
question just to give some context
that's again that's willow cottage and
that is the
proposed primary school site the
community and employment hub
so access at the moment to the
application site is in the corner here
that is proposed to be planted up so it
won't be used
and access will be via the main
roundabout which get which
goes into the main spine road and then
the access will come off there
so to give members some context to the
site as existing
i've got a series of photographs just to
give an indication of of
of the direction i'm facing in i've
tried to put um
the redline plan i've referred to
earlier in there with it with an arrow
so it just gives
gives you maybe a clearer indication of
of of the
of where i'm looking at on the site so
effectively we've got airfield house so
this is looking north with airfield
house
we've got the scrap yard to the rear and
then this is the proposed primary school
site here so effectively we're looking
at the red line
round about that place there
so moving towards the center of the site
again looking towards airfield house
you've got some of the um scrapyard
buildings to the rear
excuse me and willow cottage to the east
you can just see the
i think it's just the chimney of
property there
so this is looking towards the front so
the lma 400 site i referred to is is
roughly in that location
and you can see the access to um to
camden road
just there and just going
slightly north but still looking east so
the the access is there
and that's the existing um boundary
treatment to camden road which is
looking to be reinforced
as part of the of the application which
i'll show you on the parameters plan
later on
and willow cottage is just further over
there
so this is looking towards long marston
airfield
approximately where the where the access
will be coming out you can see the
proposed primary school site to the
right there
and just in the distance here you can
see the houses which are starting to be
built for
long marston airfield so the entrance
roundabout is
is roughly in that area and these are
the stone properties which effectively
will be fronting that access roundabout
so this is the towards the east looking
towards the eastern boundary
of the site so looking north so
willow cottage is over there so that's
effectively the boundary of the site
along there
and to the north of the site to the
north of airfield house just to get your
bearings you can see the existing scrap
yard which is which is ceased operating
now
and this is some of the hard standing
and buildings which would be
removed as part of the application
so this is this is looking southwards
with
uh back to the scrapyard effectively
looking back towards airfield house
and you can just see the hedgerow which
was in the uh which was in the first
photograph
just just for bearings
now as part of the application the the
applicant has submitted an
an illustrated illustrative master plan
um this is to give an indication of how
60
dwellings would be accommodated on the
site
so what you can see on here is the
entrance roundabout
that's the community and employment hub
an application for which is in that
hasn't been granted yet
so you can see how the access would also
serve the community and employment hub
would go through the school sites and
for
an illustrative purposes it's showing
how how a car
some car parking for the school could be
accommodated in that
to access to and from the um from the
access road and
and members will note that there is a
contribution has been secured
um a 45 000 pound towards a towards a
zebra crossing there
so then that would go into the site um
and you can see the sort of the possible
arrangement which might be in place in
terms of the
of the dwellings and the the drainage
and again there's willow cottage and the
moat
in terms of the nearest residential
properties
so as one of the approved plans would be
this parameters plan which if
granted outline permission this would
inform any reserve
matter that would come in so effectively
it sets the number of
of thresholds if you like say for
example
an area where there'll be a maximum
height of two and a half stories
and two-story property a setback from
the camden road
the reinforced planting to the front of
the site
which includes blocking up of the
existing access which i referred to
boundary planting as well and open space
treatment to the north where there would
be suds proposed
and there will be outward facing
development as well
and potential links through to the
adjoining long marston airfield sites
um the this is the
access the proposed access road
so you can see the access arrangements
again the community and employment hub
down there which is currently subject to
application this
is the um the primary school site
and that's the application site in there
as well
so the application the access is being
proved as part part of the um
of the proposed application
um and finally um this is the demolition
plan
showing the the hard standing extent of
the hard standing and the
buildings which will be removed as part
of the proposed development
so chairman there are 10 updates as
detailed in the update sheets
including confirmation that the climate
change checklist condition would expect
the use of
electric vehicle charging electric
vehicles charging points and tool
properties
the proposal is for an outline
application for the erection of up to 60
dwellings of all matters reserved the
appearance
landscaping layout and scale accept
access to be determined including
demolition of existing dwelling and
scrap yard buildings and associated
works
chairman the application is recommended
for approval as detailed in the
committee report
and the updated details in the committee
update sheet
together with the completion of a legal
agreement thank you
now thank you very much indeed um let's
move to our first speaker who is
councillor robert spooner chairman
of clinton parish council good evening
and welcome please do come forward
while you're setting yourself in i shall
tell the members i should have said in
my disclosures earlier i live in quentin
i completely forgot to say that but i'm
still here with an open mind but i
just wanted to let you all know
mr spooner good evening you're most
welcome to take off your mask while
you're sat there if you don't want to i
also understand that
perfect thank you very much just a quick
quick breath
you have three minutes um we will give
you a third second warning before your
time is
up otherwise whenever you're ready do
feel free to start
to wear this application to come forward
with an operational relief road in place
i believe
we may now be giving no objection to the
housing as adding 60
to potentially thousands locally and
being physically on the periphery of
potentially 3500
the impact would be minimal but i'm here
to object on behalf of quinton
parish council to note though with all
other already permitted housing under
construction and an oversupply of the
core strategy requirement
we don't believe the housing is needed
anyway
primary objection is to get more traffic
on the b-4632 camden road
and the adjoining choke points
particularly clopton bridge
and seven meadows road which now
additionally has the marina under
construction
the applicant has engaged a company to
deliver a traffic assessment
to achieve their objective to indicate a
greater capacity exists on the road
system
in a meeting with them it claimed that
the road could take another thousand
cars
when asked do you mean physically fit on
the road the answer was yes
they could indeed by adding to the cues
already taking place
never mind the bigger ones in the future
as committed housing is occupied
such further pollution in these times of
climate emergency must be prevented
three or four years ago i used to travel
weekdays on the bus towards stratford
and the bus then used the shipston road
and copton bridge
not once did i stay on the bus to get
off at the bus stop by the shell garage
i got off and walked and i would always
beat the bus and sometimes it even
remained out of sight
the bus route was changed to using seven
meadows road inbound to town avoiding
this particular congestion
two weeks ago i used the bus for the
first time in 15 months and once again
it used the shipstand road and clopton
bridge
and once again it joined the queue on
the shipston road
i got off and walked and beat it to the
shale roundabout
as traffic volumes return so has
congestion and of course as yet
without the additional housing still
being built on the unveil
up to 380 or more houses being built
immediately south of the unveiling the
whitshaven district
and for which a connecting roundabout
has been built in quentin parish
nor without the 400 houses under
construction on long marston airfield
additionally planning permission was
granted for the long marston depot to
store hundreds of more vehicles
these needing to arrive and depart
sometimes on transporters sometimes
driven
i'm in me unveil most days and see far
more of these than i thought from the
planning application
this morning i noticed five transporters
in five minutes
30 seconds no amount of tweaking the
junctions on the
b4632 the weight rolls around about his
joists an adjacent roundabout changes
the bottlenecks at clopton bridge
and along seven meadows road where
traffic often queues all the way to the
birmingham road
where it usually queues again this
application should only be progressed
once there's an operational bypass for
the bottlenecks for example the road
referred to as the southwest relief road
modeling is just that the real world
world is what we're seeing now
maybe some of the plenty committee also
drive these routes lastly this
development would further burden the
schooling and medical facilities
that as stated are faced with a thousand
more already permitted houses
council espionage thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our parish council please
no none in that case council spanish
thank you very much
i see you're already wiping away so
thank you for that thank you for your
contribution as well
i have wiped many a seat at the
vaccination for me and i'm well used to
it
good man if you'd like a job for the
evening you're most welcome to stay
good man there should be a bin somewhere
to the side
council jenny is there a bin just next
to you
thank you
well cancer journey is doing that we'll
call forward our next speakers who are
reuben bellamy and jonathan thompson now
gents before you come forward who is
going to be doing the speaking because
as you can see we only have one chair
okay reuben do come forward jonathan are
you going to be answering questions
okay if we need you we'll call you
forward at that stage we obviously need
to make sure that we're maintaining the
right distances
okay reuben you have three minutes we'll
give you a 30 second warning
otherwise whenever you're ready to feel
free to start
you you'll if you press the middle
button it should go red
all right sorry everybody um good
evening ladies and gentlemen yes my name
is ruben bellamy and alongside me is
jonathan thompson
available to answer questions i set out
in the report
our proposal complies with the key core
strategy policy as11
on rural brownfield sites the site is
brownfield as it is part of the original
airfield
and part of the site was a scrap yard
which is contaminated
this brownfield site is a is unique in
sustainability terms because it adjoins
the garden village
the approved phase one contains a shop
employment and the community hub
facility
and there are the off-site cycle off of
carriageway cycle links to the
surrounding villages
neon vale and to stratford itself and
our scheme will provide pedestrian
cyclings into the garden village
enabling future residents to access the
new facilities including the proposed
shop
helping to sustain them and as we set
out in our climate change checklist
we propose the eev charging points for
all of the dwellings
and these factors we believe show that
the scheme addresses your guidance
on climate change adoption we've
undertaken an extensive community
consultation exercise and given
presentations to the local parish
councils
including quinton and john our highway
expert recently gave a further in-person
presentation to quinton parish council
the key issues is highways as we've just
heard and living in stratford it's
something that we both understand as
well
in response to the consensus raised and
from the detailed feedback from
warwickshire county council further
modelling work has been undertaken
this has demonstrated that the impact of
60 dwellings on the highway network
is acceptable in policy terms the
modeling has also demonstrated that the
in combination impact with the phase 1a
application at lma is also acceptable
which means that approving this
application if you do this evening will
not present
prevent the next phase of lma from
coming forward
we know that peak time congestion has
returned to the bamboo and shipston
roads
but it's worth noting that the capacity
improvements required by the loxi road
carla's 400 scheme and me unveil have
not yet been implemented
onto all the matters a policy compliant
35
affordable homes is proposed a policy
compliant market mix is proposed
the draft section 106 agreement is well
advanced with over six hundred thousand
pounds of planning gain
which will be delivered in addition to
the full community infrastructure levy
we believe our indicative layout shows
that sixty dwellings can be accommodated
whilst complying with your design
policies
in conclusion we consider the
development complies with your core
strategy
a contaminated brownfield site will be
remediated that will support the
delivery of the garden village and
provide 21 affordable homes
30 seconds your draft site allocation
plan
identified that there is capacity for
750 dwellings in this area above the
consented 400
at the garden village this is supported
by our detail modeling undertaken for
this application
that has demonstrated that the highway
impact test is achieved
we hope that you will be able to support
your officer's recommendation
thank you very much and yes we're here
to take questions thank you
perfect thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions
please counselor mills please
thanks mr chairman um mr bellamy uh
actually it's something you said um on
the side your presentation you said
the land is contaminated
yes well correct the particularly the
area around the old scrap yard
has got quite some severe contamination
which um
we will be obviously cleaning up as part
of the proposal should we get planning
permission
right said that i mean does it go deep
does it this is
contamination um you know it's moving
around deep it's going
good afternoon councillor um we've
undertaken a very detailed
uh report by rsk consultants who have
surveyed the wider long marston airfield
site
um they've produced a detailed
remediation strategy that's been
submitted to your environmental health
officer
so as a result was a very clear action
plan in terms of how detailed it goes
i think it's something like half a meter
there's some perched
contaminated water that sits underneath
the concrete slab
the plan will be to remove that concrete
slab and will be to remove and excavate
all of that
and it will be treated on site it won't
be hauled off site
thank you very much thank you okay mommy
do we have anyone else with a question
please no in that case gentlemen thank
you very much for your contribution if
you could
give the desk a quick wipe down and the
microphone that would be great
uh while you're doing that we will carry
on we have not got
a ward member registered to speak this
evening so we will move to points for
clarification for our officers
does anyone have a question for
clarification please
the cancer feeling
this is part and parcel with a much
bigger scheme
which i think you're proposing and so
therefore
all the um we're only just dealing with
this one site at the moment
so highways and other matters that
around this scheme will be coming
forward at a later stage is that correct
i mean in in respect of this application
the matter which is being looked at is
the access
so that's being approved that's been put
forward for approval as part of this
the impact on the highway network has
also been assessed as part of this
application
so the wider impact of the the traffic
generated by the site has been has been
assessed as part of this application
that mean you've been looking at it
north
and west of the site as well as along
the camden road
there's been a lot of detailed modelling
been undertaken
and i would say extensive modelling been
undertaken in respect to this
application
i know we have the highways officer from
the county council
here who may well be able to give some
more clarification on the modeling
exercise if that would help i'm
going to dive in there and say yes it
probably would because my question is
going to be about
the highways okay um so i'm going to
assume that i i can't see our
highways expert on my screen i'm
assuming he's hearing this um
my understanding of the lma site whilst
it's not
this site uh mine's saying anime site is
the first 400 could come forward
and then anything over and above that
would require some form
of uh relief road or similar
um my concern is that we've got 60 more
coming in here without that
and i suppose it's the same point that
the parish council were making so i just
want to understand what modeling has
been done to allow or to say that we can
have more cars than we had under a
previous
application yes
um you're absolutely right that the
policy does talk about the relief road
coming in
but that the the wording of the policy
says
um unless modeling shows you know
appraisal unless modelling shows that
capacity can be
um that can be accommodated on the uh on
the highway network
so that's what the modeling is is
showing but it
might be that mr pilcher can give some
more
um clarification in respect to that i
think that would be very helpful mr
peter if you could come in at that point
please yes uh thank you chair i'm not
sure if you can hear me i
don't think we did a sound check at the
beginning i'm hoping that you can
uh mr pushes just just bear with us a
second though we we
unfortunately we can't hear you for some
reason ah
we're just you're just being turned on
or turned up sorry
although we appear to be turning up the
heating
i have requested that the john not now
please
okay
okay mr we appear to have uh screens
working and things so could you speak
more see if we can hear you
okay can you hear me now you're on yes
and nailed it thank you so over to you
even i can hear me in the background um
uh yes as neil said we we've undertaken
significant modelling in respect to this
and i think um i need to take
take members a step back from from this
application
um we've we've carried out some modeling
assessments based on the the
areas that we've been asked to look at
for uh local plan
reviews um from planning policy which
has identified that with
using mobile network data over and above
the um
the previously used census data it's
actually given us a little bit more of
an accurate forecast of
traffic distribution and traffic
patterns in the area
what that identified as part of the
local plan review was that we
could have i think 700 units in this
area
and and the the road network would have
the capacity to cope with that
however when we initially modeled this
um
this proposal and kept in all of the
committed
and other local plan sites it did
actually show
that there was a problem at clopton
bridge and at seven meadows road
now what we've done and the problem with
modeling is it all throws everything in
at the peak hour so we've done a
sensitivity test which which
spreads out that traffic so it doesn't
actually take over an hour it takes it
over a
slightly longer period of time which is
a more real life situation
and that does actually show that
although there are some slight
increases in queuing at the junctions at
clockton bridge
and um shipston road the um
is still within capacity so we've got to
the point where we haven't got any
grounds to object to this under the mppf
policies because it's not demonstrating
the severe impact
uh furthermore when the shotery relief
road comes forward those those
cues all but disappear so we have done a
lot of work on it and we are satisfied
that the
um the network can cope with the the
traffic from this
and from the other current application
for 124 units nearby
okay thank you that's very clear and
helpful um the modeling you've done with
the i think you said mobile data
um was that done has that been done in
the last 12 months or just over the last
12 months when we've been locked down or
was it done before that
well mobile network data works on
proportions
so it doesn't really matter on the level
of traffic that's on
on the highway um it just says that so
many percentage
goes north so many percentage goes south
et cetera so
that those proportions have remained
fairly consistent
but we don't use survey data prior to
march 2020 so anything that we are
assessing is based on on pre-covered
traffic
levels it's all based on pre-covered
traffic levels all based on pre-covered
traffic that's what i wanted to know
okay members do we have any other
questions for mr pilcher while he's on
the line i'm going to start with
councillor crump
afternoon um yes just to just make sure
just for clarity really
so based on on the modeling um
you're saying that it would be
unreasonable
to put in an objection and you'll be
open to challenge if we did
you if you did um you'd be open to
challenge on that
it doesn't show a serious impact on the
holiday network so yes
we wouldn't be able to subject
okay thank you very much councillor
curtis please
thank you chair um thanks um
mr pilcher um just one comment that you
um
mentioned pretty much as a matter of
fact that the shot really
shuttery relief road will be delivered
but that isn't actually necessarily a
given is it
so what would happen if the funding
from government doesn't come through
that because i think particularly
now we're in a very different economic
situation i don't think we can
expect that that is a given so what if
it doesn't happen
thank you would that be the shotery
relief road which is
part of the development that's ongoing
at the moment or are you referring to
the south western relief road
the southwest relief road so i assume
that's what you were referring to
sorry the shuttery relief road is
committed development which will be
uh carried out in due course as part of
that development of shotery
the southwestern relief road is
uncommitted development so it was
excluded from
our modeling scenarios so we just
assumed that it wasn't going to happen
so so all of the scenarios that i've
talked about are assuming that that
south western relief road the bridge
over the river
doesn't happen in in this plan period
thank you for that clarification okay
any more questions either for mr pilcher
or for
neil no okay members that's moving uh
mr butcher thank you very much if you
want to stay on uh you can you can
listen to the debate
members we're opening up the debate who
would like to kick us off
council jennings well this one that
is one of the most comprehensive reports
that i've seen and i think i'd like to
commend the officers or
involved in this it's it's sort of it's
quite a quite a
quite a project um
in my view it's a brownfield site
you have to make use of brownfield sites
21 affordable homes are very welcome
we do need housing highways are
satisfied
um i'm happy to go along and propose
that we go
along with the officer's recommendations
and grant this application
thank you very much council jennings
anyone else like to come in at that
point councillor mills
thanks mr chairman yes um i i appreciate
the concerns of the
objectives it it is a it's a well used
road and getting
getting busier and busier as we get into
stratford it gets sniled up
personally i i do feel for the um
the objectives but highways have said
it's
it can take it um it remains to be seen
i'm
i'm on the fence on this one and my miss
chairman i just see what everybody else
has to say thank you
okay thank you very much cancer feeling
i agree with um
counselor jennings it is a well thought
out scheme it is part and parcel with
the concept that has been put forward by
the district council
it is also going to be part of the
expansion of the
green village using um
i believe employment situations around
it
and i'm in favor of um and second what
has been said by
council jennings that's the second thing
to his proposal just so i'm clear
yep okay uh we have a pros and con does
anyone else want to say anything at this
point council dixon
thank you chairman um obviously during
the covid uh pandemic
um more and more people have been
working from home
and working flexible hours which could
indeed have an impact upon
traffic volumes at peak times which is
where an assessment was made
so certainly i'm i'm in support of the
proposal
and uh the second as such but i'm
wondering if it could possibly be
appropriate
whilst it will be a reserve matter to
add a note to any
agreement if committee are supportive
of asking the developers to perhaps
consider
provision for home working within the
design of what does come forward
um okay
i i mean as our proposal and second
they're happy to put that on as a note i
think we need to be mindful that it has
to be fit with policy but
are you happy that you put that as a
note is it absolutely necessary
that's fine you're waving your hand
cancer i'm happy with that because i
think we're going to be
doing more homework as most of our poor
planners are having to do at the moment
um so i'm in favor of incorporating that
message i would like some advice before
i go
before i did that understood please
honest thank you chairman
um we do have a policy cs22
um which kind of encourages facilities
for homework it's obviously only
encouraged
um i wouldn't suggest a condition in any
sort of sense but
um i think a note is always helpful if
members are keen to see
that kind of facility presumably if i
can just get clarification from
councillor dixon
that it's um you're sort of not thinking
live work units you're more thinking
like a home office so that people have
facilities in their home just to
do work like we are doing indeed perhaps
perhaps
perhaps larger than the a four by four
study but uh certainly
perhaps you know space over the top of a
garage or something like that
but not not to live work fine fine yeah
but
encouragement of home working if you
like because i think broadband is a
requirement isn't it without
within the conditions in any case it is
yes so so absolutely i think that that
is something we we could add quite
quite recently onto any forthcoming
permission okay lovely
that makes it clear so um happy with
that cancer genius
as long as it's not a condition i i
fully agree with you on that
council feeling you've already said yes
give me a thumbs up yeah lovely okay in
that case let's move to a vote
so the proposal is to grant in line with
the officer's recommendation
and including a note to suggest uh some
form of thought towards homeworking
um as discussed uh could we please have
a show of transformation
is you an ims yet okay in that case
committee resolves to grant application
twenty zero
two seven four five out on airfield
house
okay let's move to our next uh item
which is application reference twenty
zero three two eight six ful that's land
adjacent to 201
loxley rose our presenting officer is
sarah chadwick
who i can't see at the moment so we'll
just call her in
and we'll get going bear with us
see please bear with us members of the
public this is the joys of our
world at the moment everything has to be
carefully cleaned
thank you
so as soon as you're ready sarah you're
able to share your screen do feel free
to
keep on
perfect thank you chairman
the application site is a greenfield
site within the built-up area boundary
of stratford
the site is level and accessed via an
existing field access from loxley road
the site is banded on all sides by
residential development
this is a full planning application for
the erection of seven dwellings with
associated bin collection point
hard surfacing and landscaping
off-street parking is provided to the
front of each of the proposed dwellings
the elevations can be seen on this slide
the dwellings are a mixture of two
three and four bed units with five
detached dwellings and units three and
four being
semi-detached they would all feature
porches and chimneys and plots six and
seven would benefit
from garages the dwellings would vary in
height
from 8.2 to 8.7 metres
here we are stood on loxley road looking
in a northerly direction into the site
itself
this photo is taken looking in an
easterly direction towards the site
with the spitfire dwellings part of the
urban heat development scene in the
background
this image is taken from the north west
of the site looking towards the site
entrance with the dwellings on loxley
road and the arden heat development seen
in the background
chairman please refer to the update
sheet for an update relating to the
removal of the town council objection
the principal development is acceptable
as is the design impact on neighbouring
immunity and highway safety
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the application subject to the
conditions and reasons set out on pages
79 and 80 of your agenda packs
thank you serious marvelous thank you
very much indeed
uh we will have our first speak for this
item which is mr doug glasford
uh would you mind coming forward please
mr glassford for members of benefit is
our agent
mr glasswood you'll have three minutes
whenever you're ready you'll have three
minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning
make yourself as comfortable as you can
and when you're ready press the button
in the middle
and you'll feel free to start
chairman members of the committee thank
you very much for the opportunity to
address you tonight
i i just want to address two issues
which
i think are relevant to the application
and also to a site visit that the
you undertook this morning the first one
is
is access we've had
various discussions with the county
highways on this matter
uh we now have a situation where we've
satisfied their requirements
the existing hedge along the frontage
which
has not been maintained over many years
uh
we're not sure whether that all needs to
come out whether something has been
retained
however the landscape proposals we put
forward
uh indicate that if the hedge does need
to be removed
a replacement hedge will be planted at
the front
and uh the height of the hedge when it's
initially planted will be somewhere
between a meter
and a meter and a half in height so that
will protect
the existing situation that exists at
the moment
the other area of seems to be of some
concern is
levels and loss of immunity
the proposal is to
work with the existing levels on the
site uh
we do appreciate that the surrounding
development under construction by
spitfire
is somewhat higher but we feel that it's
important to work with existing levels
keep the units at ground level and
the units along the front on loxley road
do step
up slightly as you go from the boundary
with
number 201 towards their heath
development
the the units themselves on the site uh
the separation distances all exceeds uh
the requirements within your account spd
uh and we feel that that gives a level
of
uh privacy to not just the units
the proposed units but to the units
around the site
not only on 201 but also on the spitfire
development
so we feel that we've looked to address
all the concerns
all the issues and we feel that we have
a development which is a good transition
between
the existing properties in loxley road
and
the development currently under
construction as part of the arden heath
uh development thank you very much
i was just about to give you your 30
second warning so that's ideal timing
thank you
members do we have any questions for the
applications agents council dixon please
thank you chairman uh mr glassford you
mentioned this
the hedge uh on that verge side that
it could be cut back and if need be it
could be replaced
would the intention be in the
landscaping plan if we are minded to
support it be a situation whereby the
hedge would be replaced
in the same situation or with obviously
saplings
or would the new new hedge be planted
say a meter further back
the the intention uh is
if the existing hedge needs to be
removed
the only reason it would need to be
removed is to provide the
visibility requirements and at the
moment
we're not sure whether we can get the
visibility splay in
without having to take any of the hedge
out
if we do have to take the hedge out then
the intention is that we would then
uh plant a new hedge uh and
what we'd be looking at doing is they
almost got an instant hedge
it's container grown and it comes at a
height of between a meter and a meter
and a half
so that that just gets dropped into the
ground so that what you have it's not
just saplings in the ground
that you're assuming will grow to the
required heights within a period of time
it's it's it's there to give the
instant uh screening that you know the
existing hedge currently gives
if i may follow up chairman i'm not i'm
not too concerned about the height
i'm concerned about the width because
that existing hedge
does obscure a lot of the road
from as it currently is i appreciate i'm
talking about having it cut back
but if a new hedge was planted in the
same place and was allowed to grow
to exactly the same sort of dimensions
as the current hedge
you would have a problem
well we'd be looking to to plant it far
enough back within the site
so that any future growth doesn't
obscure the visibility display
thank you very much members do we have
any other questions please
no okay mr glasswood thank you very much
indeed
if you wouldn't mind giving the desk a
quick wipe down before we welcome
councillor rolfe that would be great
okay counselor ralph welcome
you know the drill by now you do have
five minutes i'll give you a 30
30-second warning before that time's up
otherwise feel free to start whenever
you're ready
thank you chairman um thank you to those
who came to the site visit today where i
was able to show you some
concerns i don't know whether you're
aware but at 11 o'clock i showed a
councillor henshaw seraphin and council
of fielding around because they thought
the site visit was eleven o'clock
firstly land level of the site it is
absolutely critical that the land level
near to 201 loxi road remains
that it is as it is and it is not raised
as some of you saw this morning standing
on the raised patio of number 201
it would be so intrusive even if the
level raised a few inches
if this were to be approved this must be
a firm condition
secondly on a site visit with the
developer and the planner and the
residents of 201 a few weeks ago
the developers agreed verbally and i
believe there is an email but no detail
to put in shielding measure
measures between the two i would hope
that is if this application is a proof
that the developers keep to their word
and put something in something in which
is mutually beneficial
to all and keep dialogue going between
themselves and the occupiers of 201
now i believe you've all been sent
photographs of cars
exiting 201 loxley road um
have you all been sent that thank you so
thirdly and most
importantly i am not convinced that the
visibility display is good enough
and safe enough when exiting from this
proposed development
currently as you all saw there is a
hedge along the line
but my belief that even removing this
hedge there will still be the bend in
the road making it difficult for sight
to the right when exiting
i noted that councillor richards um
walked down and and halfway down
was not seen by people standing in that
entrance
measurements confirming the visibility
display is okay
it's all well and good but as you all
saw this morning when it comes to seeing
it on site
i think you are all aware of how tricky
exiting this development is going to be
i really don't think we can compromise
safety and until you've all seen this
site with the hedge removed
and whatever is put in its place you
will not know whether access and egress
is possible
safely i would urge you all not to make
any decision
until you are absolutely sure that this
is the case
now i also note and i'm at living here i
also note from the
agent that he may remove some of the
hedge he may remove all of the hedge
he may put a hedge in but whatever is
put in
is going to compromise seriously
compromise the visibility display
and i you know it's all very well when
highways give you
figures and accept figures that the
developer's given but in reality and
some of you saw this morning um it's not
the case
it is actually quite dangerous um and if
you look at those pictures from 201 they
have a mirror opposite them
in order to get out safely and further
on when this
where this access is i believe it's even
more dangerous
so thank you very much thank you very
much cancer rolf members do we have any
questions for our world counsellor
no in that case cancer roth thank you
very much for contribution and thanks
for helping this morning
okay we'll move to point clarification
for our offices
um i will kick us off if i may um
sarah we've heard from uh council ralph
there about levels
i note there is a pre-commencement
levels condition in condition nine
are you satisfied or can you satisfy me
that um
the that is robust enough to ensure the
levels
on this site as is existing will be
maintained
[Music]
chair i think as the condition states in
your gender pact it says the existing
and proposed finished floor level so
i think it will be quite clear that if
there's any disparity alice if there's
anything you'd like to add
uh yeah absolutely i think the only
other thing i'd add is that what we
would expect on a plan is to show spot
levels
on land adjacent to the site boundary as
well so we'd expect the level to be
provided
on where the neighbours 201sland ends as
well as within the site itself so we can
easily compare and see if there are any
sort of land level changes but like
sarah said we would expect the site to
stay
at the same level as it is now okay i'm
satisfied with that
um the visibility displays and the
potential to remove the hedge does the
hedge
will the hedge be included or has it
been included in
the hard and soft landscaping scheme if
it has
does it have any detail of how it will
be maintained so that we can ensure and
be satisfied that that visibility
display
if achieved will be achieved in
perpetuity
um i would say again in condition four
it says we've said notwithstanding the
submitted details so this has been
submitted at application stage this
landscaping plan but i would say it is
indicative
and full details will be secured via the
condition
which obviously will also relate to the
height the position the land
all of that yeah just to come in on that
absolutely we would get a more detailed
landscaping plan
um to show exactly where the hedge is
going to be located once we know what's
happening with that display and whether
the existing hedge needs to be cut down
and replaced somewhere else the other
thing i was worth saying
is that we that hard and soft
landscaping condition would include
a caveat that requires replanting within
five years if any of the planting fails
so that would ensure that
it's retained for that period at least
and then in addition to that we've got
condition 10 which requires visplay
so that although we don't have the full
wording it basically means that
we can't have any structures within the
display place and that includes
vegetation so
the applicant will need to make sure
that when designing the location of the
hedge and the
um species to be put there that it's not
going to encroach into those displays
otherwise they're then contravening
condition 10 of the permission
and if they were to contribute let's say
that was happening they had to grow out
and you couldn't
maintain the visibility in six years
time for example
how how do we then make sure that it is
put back
so that it does have the display so it
would then be down to enforcement to
look into
and it would very much depend on what
the arrangement is when the site is sold
so whether they have a management
company to
maintain that that strip of land because
of the the size of development it is
they don't have a section 106
do for biodiversity offsetting but not
for pos maintenance or management
so that would be down to the applicant
and then if they transfer it to the
owners
it would be down to them to maintain
okay
right i'm satisfied with that the final
question i have is the
um we heard about shielding measures um
along the
uh north boundary i think next to 201
um i can see a hedge on the indicative
plan here
is there anything we need to add in to
ensure those shielding measures are in
place and notes or additional conditions
are you satisfied that
you are over the understanding the and
the applicant is of the understanding
that something will need to be put that
as um i think as rose stated this was
discussed at the site visit between
herself
the uh agent and myself and the neighbor
at number 201
and we agreed that a wall would be
suitable
um i think it would be appropriate to
secure the details of that via that
landscaping condition
if that would be sufficient to ensure
that do we need to put a note
or are you satisfied that this
discussion and is very clear to you and
to the applicant
that that is the case that will happen
through that conditioning i think i
would say i'm satisfied
yeah that's a hashtag if members wanted
to attach a note just to sort of set the
expectation of what we expect through
the submission of the to discharge that
condition
that a certain screen would be provided
then
then we could put that on to sort of aid
the
the application discharge process um but
it's
it's really up to members whether you
would like to do that
okay that's lovely thank you very much
casanova's did you indicate you had a
question
sorry mr chairman i'm sort of slow on
the uptake on this one
as usual um the levels as we see
they will remain the same so
fine yeah that's fine that's
all i need to know thank you cancer
feeling
the land along the front which is
with the which contains that large hedge
is that
highways land or is it going to be
part and parcel with the developers land
because if it's highways wasteland are
we going to be able to get highways to
maintain it
i do have a plan here showing the
visibilities place which
the land in green is the land maintained
by highways so if we can do a kind of
comparison of
the landscaping plan
it looks to be set back behind that line
um from what i can tell i
agree yeah absolutely i don't
have much to add i'm in agreement with
that do you have a follow-up
yeah could we get that
the um developer to bring back
that wall of probably two meters so that
it does
give a lot better splay or a lot better
visibility
and the other comment is with regards to
that wall we were talking about
would that be possible to work it or get
the agreement of the neighbor
so that we come up with a scheme that
suits both parties
the um landscaping would be controlled
by the condition the pre-commencement
condition which would be assessed by
officers
there wouldn't be any chance for the
neighbor to be consulted on that
um i think there will be a clear
expectation that the war would need to
be included on that and the hedging
should be set
outside of displays and that'll be up to
officers to determine whether the
information submitted with the discharge
of conditions was sufficient for that um
yeah just to reiterate we don't consult
on discharge condition applications and
that's not something we
do look to do in this case
council dixon i think you indicated i
did thank you chairman
um do we know if when highway is
producing
their design as such for the site
displays
whether or not that was a desktop
analysis or whether it was after a site
visit would they normally do a site
visit for a scheme this size
i have to say i would need to check the
highways officer's response on the file
to
check if they've been to the site would
that make a material difference to your
decision making tonight
i am aware in the past german that
they have suggested site space
which highways said were achievable
locals said
were not they subsequently were not
delivered
okay um fine
council from um obviously we've got the
county council officer here
uh a lot of these questions have
referred to registered displays and
some uncertainty whether it was a
desktop or actual visit
uh should be asking the officer from the
county to these questions direct
if i can come through you chairman dave
pilcher responded to the previous
application he didn't respond to this
one it's not
the type of application we would
generally have involvement from a
highways officer from a committee we've
got the consultation response which says
no objection
and that's based on a level of
information which that officer thought
was sufficient to be able to
to come to that conclusion i suppose we
could ask the general question of
whether this type of site would be one
a desk-based one okay i i'm not going to
go into that because i think that's just
going far too far
the reality is we have um and no
objection from the highways authority
and we have a very clear um condition
that requires
visibility space to be met or whether
they
conducted an on-site or a desk base i
think is irrelevant
provided those visibility supplies can
be met because if you're
if you're unhappy with it no i'm not i'm
happy about that at all far from it you
know i'm happy with the visibility
displays but
listening to cancer dixon and his
opinion and
how it might affect his vote you know i
think we should have some clarity
perhaps not here but for future meetings
um because it might
change people's opinion you know i've
got no problems with the visit these
displays and from what i've heard from
the offices um but it
just that council dixon had raised the
question and whilst
you know we've got an officer
unfortunately he didn't do this one it
was there for the previous one
it might have been an opportune an
opportunity to uh
to answer it but okay i understand your
point and i i and it's valid but i don't
think we do that in a public forum i
think we do that outside of this public
forum
but again being transparent and open
you know i agree that you know we should
be clear what we're doing in front of
the public
and how these decisions are made so
again
i can understand from from a time point
of view that we need to be
pressing on but again i think we we need
to have this
error of openness and transparency about
it and how these decisions are made
and how the ward member who i don't
agree with her
on this but the ward member is is coming
up with a different view about the
disability space so
that's that's just raising this concern
sir i'll believe it
do we have any other points of
clarification please counselor curtis
oh that's better um just on um on the
access [ __ ] can i just
uh or can officers clarify um
refuse collection will refuse lawyers be
going in and out of that egress as well
two seconds i just got the plan up um if
you can see my cursor but there's a bin
collection point here
so on collection days the bins will be
put in this place so
they'll be able to present it at the
highway but they're if you can see
there's a
vehicle tracking [ __ ] that's a delivery
lorry but um yeah
the bins are to be collected from that
point i mean
on the site visit this morning it is a
nasty bend so so
would would ben lawrence go into the
site for collection because i can see
problems
either way there's a problem of
accessing egress if they
are going in on that pretty nasty bend
and if they're not going in
then they're parking on a bend
i understand your concerns i would
direct your attention to the response
from the waste and refuse officer on
page 76 of the agenda who
has said no comment in response to the
addition of the bing collection point
okay and sure can we just make one
another point um
i also share concerns about site levels
i am reassured by mr glassman's comments
that
um you know they will be adhered to but
i would
like it to be really clearly noted
um that the committee if we do approve
it would be approved on the express
expectation
that these conditions on site levels
will be enforced
thank you chair
thank you and just for everyone's
benefit while we were
hearing your points there we have had a
message from uh dave pilcher our high
was officers confirmed that he
and another colleague have conducted a
site visit
okay let's move on to the debate
councillor jennings right and i i
appreciate
the board members concerns but this all
comes down to highways
for me highways are satisfied we seem to
have some
very robust conditions and they're very
comprehensive and detailed um
i'm more than happy to go along with the
officer's recommendations
and uh recommend a recommended approval
great i'm gonna accept that as a formal
proposal um councilman mills you're
indicated first
yeah yes thanks mr chairman yes um i did
go
along on a site visit over the weekend
i'm sorry i couldn't join you this
morning
uh my concern was the the
the um the levels and that's
uh you've confirmed that they're gonna
stay the same
i couldn't see where the ward members
coming from that um
if they were raised up it would over
shadow the adjoining uh
buildings but no i'm happy with that and
i'm quite happy to second uh councillor
jennings
thank you very much cancer kendall
council mills beat me to it on the
second
so i'm happy to go ahead thank you can't
send you seraphin
thank you chair yes i did visit this
morning
11 o'clock an hour late but uh
thankfully uh
the ward member came out and showed me
all the
sights i am concerned of display
even though you cut the hedge back it's
the bend
you cannot see what is coming around
that bend
that access is too close to the bend
it it would be better if the access was
further to the right
where it's straighter i'm giving more
time to come out
because even though cutting the hedge
back
where the boundary is 201
is blocking the view coming round the
bend it's quite serious really
and we had trouble coming across the
road
at several times we went backwards and
forwards and
i think that's
i'm not comfortable with that at all
i think the access needs to be altered
ah i'm back on sorry about that
technical glitch all speakers
broken uh we're back in the game okay uh
councillor henderson thank you very much
indeed do we have anyone else that
wishes to speak at this point um
otherwise we'll go to a vote
uh council feeling i'm just concerned
about the wall next to one oh 201
um and i actually agree with uh
counselor interests never get my name
my tongue around your name i'm terribly
sorry um
it is it could easily be moved
um more to the right more towards
spitfire
um but that's about money comments
thanks john um cancer crumpling yeah i
wasn't last week but very briefly um
i know the the town council removed
their objection
um the height we discussed this piece
displays
and we've actually confirmation of a
site visit by the officers
from the county council um i am
great and concerned about road safety in
warwickshire but
um i think we've got the information
from the officers that
that we need uh and i will be supporting
this application
thank you cancer i agree um i think the
important thing to note is there is a
condition for every one of the issues
that we've raised and unless those
conditions can be met this cannot be
built out
i just leave you with that thought
before we go to a vote we have a
proposal to grant
in line with the officer's
recommendation and the update sheet
could i plea and it has been seconded as
well could i please have a show of hands
for those in favor
one two three four five six six those
against
one abstentions
three three in that case committee
resolves to a grant
application twenty zero three two eight
six f u
l um we are going to take a very quick
one minute adjournment so that anyone
can use facilities if they need to and
then we'll be back so please one minute
from
from now
okay can we take our seats again please
as quickly as we can
members
john as quickly as you can please that's
the wrong way your seat's over there
okay well john reed takes his seat he is
here so he can take part in uh
the next item which is application
21.00561
very carriages adjacent to 27 that lead
crescent in longhitch
our presenting officer is joe brook joe
over to you
thanks chair let me just get the
presentation going
the site is located when the physical
confines of longington as indicated by
the black dot
for you the application is for a section
73 application which is seeking the
removal of condition 10 of the 2020
permission
as referenced in the officer's report
this is the approved scheme from the
2020 permission and
condition 10 was in specifics to
relation to a scheme to maintain public
access
to the rear canal presently there is
access through a fence line just here
pertinent to this application and as
referenced in the officers report is
secondary accesses to the canal and with
this is the synthesis in the other side
so
along the two boats in as you can see on
this ordinance plan
there is a public footpath here what i
would also like
members to be aware of is that if you
look at all the public footpaths are
only crescent and i haven't taken this
walk they
all lead along to this path through the
open immediate space
up to the boats in and along the canal
which is adjacent to the site which is
behind the side of the canal
the secondary access is also referenced
in report is long
stopped from road and that goes down
here coming off the road
and there is an access point here leads
off
going down the canal so you have that
access
and the two boats in and the site within
the center or
almost within the center this is
presently how it is accessed from the
garage site so you go through the two
fence line onto the canal
access this is the small access route
between the galleries and the fence line
of the lock
that's the access point there as you can
see the whole the
accessory defense line pauses
that is how it's obtained for the garage
site so you come down guys right turn
right
go into the access point this is the
access of
the crescent so you come through the
garage site
now this is the access that i just
referred to along the two boats in
so you come down the access from the
crescent two gates there
go through the two garages through the
path there's public footpaths leading up
to the boats in
up to the boats in and along the canal
that is
the point of access into the public open
space
and then the canal obviously that's two
votes in it you can just see
through the tree line and also the
access point public footprint
leading up to it this is the secondary
access point so you come down to the
road that's the canal there with the
bridge
you actually points just on the right
there's the access point
and that leads onto canal and then you
are on to the canal
and that is it regarding presentation
but in consideration the area's
development plan and national policy
and due to the fact that the application
site does not have designated footpath
and it has been demonstrated there are
alternative access points to the canal
the condition is no longer considered
necessary or reasonable
and the officer recommendation is for
removal at condition 10 as sat out in
the office report
you will also see on the update sheet
there has been a representation
submitted from house percival
on behalf of the applicant and
representation from emw
on behalf of longitudinal parish council
thank you
joe thank you very much uh we will go
straight to our first speaker who is
councillor atkins
seconds atkins from uh long engineer
parish council i'm
chairman of the parish council please do
come on forward
and it's very kindly coming over to give
you a hand with wiping of tables
or you can see that you are injured
so welcome um you have three minutes and
i'll give you a 30 second one before
that time is up otherwise
as soon as you're ready and comfortable
do feel free to start thank you
the approval for the three dwellings
originally was given by you on condition
that the public access be retained
it allows residents and canal users to
easily walk between the village and the
canal towpath
provides a safe route to school and
allows boaters to visit the local shop
the owner would face a considerable drop
in earnings if it were not there
we are asking you to stay with that
decision there is recognition within the
planning approval that a public
right-of-way exists
and its importance rests on legitimate
planning considerations found within the
core strategy
outlined in the original permission by
this planning department
and it is also consistent with our
emerging neighborhood plan
the canal and rivers trust and susterans
submitted comments stating the
importance of access to the canal pope
you have referred to other routes as
being equivalent
but one requires if you walk from model
visit village a climb
to climb a steep flight of stairs and
the other adds a third of the mile to
the journey
your officer requested evidence of plus
years of usage for this path which we
sent to him
the implication being that he too
thought this was important
but this has not been taken into account
we have applied formally to warwickshire
county council to have this public
highway recognized it is now on the
register
our legal evidence is compelling 43 user
evidence forms submitted from residents
showing continuous usage going back to
1958
this was a very genuine groundswell of
concern by the community
we didn't push people or fill in the
forms for them they were keen to
demonstrate their usage
our legal advice which you have informs
that the public right of way exists
through historical usage and currently
there is no way it can be
closed to users removing condition 10
does not change this fact and we will
consider taking the necessary steps to
protect it from closure
the applicant may argue that the
original planning approval for
three dwellings merely requires them to
build to the plans
but even if that were the case and we
dispute this
the reality of this public access will
remain
our application to change the definitive
map will appear on searches made by
prospective homeowners
home buyers we urge this committee and
bain's development to reach a pragmatic
solution
redrawing the plans to retain the access
failure to do this will not remove the
problem for them
both the parish council and the canals
and river trust would be happy to work
towards
such a solution by refusing to remove
condition 10 you would remain consistent
with your original decision
you recognize the validity and
importance of this public access
you would recognize the importance of
footpaths as stated in your own core
strategy
and you show your support for residents
rather than bound to the evident
pressure from a developer wishing to
proceed
with no regard to the local community
thank you
perfect thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions
councillor crump
please hello hi mr atkins how you doing
um yes just just come obviously you know
i know the site very well
um just just clarify
if you have to walk um from the shop
which is in the crevent or live next
from um
to two bonder locks uh through
through your carriages so if you had to
walk from the locks uh from the shop to
the locks
or by the carriages that would say be
100 to 200 meters
whereas i assume that if you have to
walk down
to the two boats then and then come back
up the other way that's probably about
three or four times as long
yeah the two boats route is longer
um and there is a flight of stairs um so
if you were coming from model village
to access the school for example you
could
do that with a pram and because you'd
have to go up a flight of stairs
thank you does anyone else have any
questions
council dixon you just mentioned the
pram we saw a photograph
uh submitted showing that access through
to the canal it would be extremely
narrow there is a narrow you can you
actually get a premise you can get a
push tear through there you couldn't get
a wheelchair through there that's true
but you could get a push chair through
there thank you
cancer fielding are you happy
casa mills thank you very much um you
mentioned
going to the school the school children
how far
where is the school adjacent to the
school is
on the stockton road north of lee
crescent
so there are a lot of families living in
model village and they use this as their
access to school it's their safe route
to school
do we have any other questions no
in that case council atkins thank you
very much indeed and we'll come and wipe
your table down thank you very much
and thank you very much indeed for that
okay our next speaker is
ross middleton the agent for the
application mr middleton do you come
forward thank you very much
so you all have three minutes i will
give you a 30-second warning whenever
you're ready do feel free to start
thank you very much chat yes i'm ross
middleton i'm an associate
employed by cc town planning who are the
applicants
retained planning consultants and
firstly thank you
for the opportunity to address you this
evening um i'm not going to go over the
points which the case officer has just
raised
going through his officers report and
and the site itself and the background
i would however like to rehear some of
the conclusions which the applicant
solicitor has reached in his assessment
of the officer's report and the case
which is in front of you this evening
their legal assessment concludes that
condition 10
cannot lawfully impose the requirement
of a
public footpath through the site in the
event that condition 10 is interpreted
to designate a public footpath through
the site
that would be an invalid interpretation
and therefore this application should be
approved to rectify that the development
plan policy is clear that such a link
would need to be provided
where it is required to mitigate any
unacceptable circumstances
arising from the proposal during the
assessment of the original application
no such unacceptable impacts have been
identified through the decision-making
process
therefore the the footpath link
is not necessary the legal submission
made on behalf of the parish council
seemingly ignores the
actual rights of weight which are
designated and which exist in vicinity
to the application site
the case in front of you is not an
established right of way
this has been confirmed by statutory
council t's in their response to this
application notwithstanding what are
suggested in submissions made on behalf
of the parish council the evidence in
front of you at this point in time
clearly points to no public footpath
having ever been established at the site
and there certainly isn't one that is
designated at this point in time they're
set up by a solicitor at binary law
to approach this application as though
such a link does exist
the parish council have obviously
highlighted that they've submitted
an application to designate a right of
way through the site however that would
be determined by
different legislation to the this this
planning application
therefore it deserves this tonight's
deliberations are seen in isolation from
that process and that this application
has judged on its own merit
to this end there are no material
considerations that this application
should be refused
and therefore members are respectfully
invited to support the officer's
professional recommendation
thank you very much indeed well within
your time members do we have any
questions please
counselor curtis thank you um
well i'm sorry this isn't actually a
question but um
the parish council um didn't i think
i'd like to just clarify they didn't
correct
they didn't um ignore that there were
other access points i think what the
parish council pointed out
was that the other foot piles are make
the journey is considerably longer and
that one of them is only accessible with
steps so i think it's
not quite true to say that they were
ignoring the other access points thank
you chair
cancer curtis i'm going to ask you to
refrain from debating
during question time well we'll save
that for the actual debate
unless there are questions for our agent
we will move on no in that case
ross thank you very much indeed for your
time and your contribution
we do have councillor adam here for
his representation council adam welcome
you're looking very fresh for a man
that's just had a little baby
congratulations
thank you very much i made it
just i would ask you all about the
family but now it's probably not the
time so
we'll stick to this stuff um you have
five minutes 30 second warning
uh as soon as you're ready do feel free
to start thank you
um yes well i mean i'm
100 behind the parish council on this
one um
it's i'll run from my arguments and i'll
try and will some up at the end
um i think the officer's recommendation
being based on
there not being a successful application
to um
register it with county isn't 100
appropriate
um the paris council has taken
um legal advice on this matter and they
found that
the common law presumption is that land
that's been dedicated as a highway
if it's been used by the public as a
right of way without interruption
um means that sorry
the land doesn't have to be used for a
defined length of time however it must
be used
for enough time to justify the inference
of the freehold owners intended
used to dedicate it as a as a highway
members of the public have
used this right um way as a right
without force
uh secrecy or permission since at least
the 1950s and that's what we've had
back and possibly um earlier um as you
heard over 40 local users provided
evidence
forms confirming that this route has
been used as a right of way i was
actually one of those people because i
have used it
myself and contrary to the officer's
report
it doesn't matter where whether the
public right-of-way has been registered
because once a public right-of-way has
come into existence it
is then protected once the public
right-of-way has come into existence it
can be neither extinguished
or diminished by disuse since it was
last
used by a member of the public so in in
short
once a highway always a highway and i
can cite the the case that that came
from
the evidence in this application has
been submitted uh to
marriage count council uh and it does
demonstrate that this is a public
highway as of as i've said
and this has as the uh parish council
noted already
led to it being added to their register
um they have been advised by the county
council though that this
uh whole process could take up to two
years for it to be added to the map
so i think it doesn't mean it's not a
highway and it's not protected it's just
not
not been added onto the map um the
assertion by the applicant
that access wouldn't would constitute
trust trespass isn't
uh accurate um the point is that if the
public right-of-way has already come
into existence through implied
uh dedication um and use then it
wouldn't be
uh be possible for the owner to close
that access
um i'd say it'd be a travesty to lose
this decades-old
um access due to a protracted working
time of
of the county council in in being able
to add that to their map
um as the officers report notes in
in the original reason for this being
added to um
to the to the as a condition um
is to ensure all reasonable steps have
been put in place to promote sustainable
travel
and also to um respect maintaining
existing public access and that's uh for
our policies
um as10 cs25 and cs26
um which i think they still apply i
think that's all appropriate um but i
also
think you could apply a number of other
one of our own policies cs7
uh requires development um proposals to
demonstrate how they contribute to
um a provision of comprehensive green
infrastructure network
through maintaining and enhancing uh
green infrastructure assets
of which the grand union canal towpath
is is one being a cycle path as well
cs9 requires all forms of development to
improve the quality of the public realm
i'd say losing this
access would certainly not do that um
cs15 requires all development in in
existing
settlements to protect and enhance the
character of the settlement
involved in setting that again wouldn't
be um
adhered to here um and also the
emergence neighborhood development plan
specifically references not supporting
applications
that have an adverse impact on access to
footpaths broader waves
and cycle routes which again this
wouldn't
be able to satisfy um there has been a
lot of local
opposition to this development um and
that's from the original application and
obviously this one
has come subsequently um it doesn't
appear that the developer has looked to
work with the
the parish council or the local
community to mitigate this
and i mean the fact that i'm here sort
of
due to my personal circumstances shows
how how much the uh
the weight of feeling is in the local
community that i want to be able to
represent them
um as fully as possible um i think this
is material because it demonstrates the
the law around highways doesn't apply
here and should be applied appropriately
and so i'd urge the committee to refuse
cancer adam thank you very much indeed
well within your time
members do we have any questions for our
counselor cancer philly
question to the um solicitor
on common john we'll wait on that this
is a question at the moment for our
oh remember my apology council please
hello lewis how you doing um yeah it's
just a question about
the um viability of the shop
um which is close by to that um
i believe that uh the
people who use the canal you know
i can't think of other proper ways for
them brain's gone sorry it's football
football fogged at the moment
and canal boat uses what's that all that
um
use the shop and if not access was
turned off
extinguished they would potentially
have to use the shop at the bottom
of the village of the co-op and use a
different route so
just wonder what your thoughts on about
accessibility and viability of
the shop for that part of the village
yeah thank you i mean that's really
pertinent and i was i was
hoping to to get to it if i had more
time i think i mean you can see from the
map
the where the shop is it's directly up
from the site
access from lee crescent um you can see
that the most
logical path from the towpath
particularly where they would want to
access
it um would be in this in this location
um i've spoken to both uh canal users
um who are people who live on the canal
people who travel along it cycle along
it all that type of thing
and they have said that this is the
route that they use to get to it
uh and i know uh from from speaking to
people in the area that
that there is a real concern about the
impact that would uh
this this application would have on the
shop
because practically speaking it would
defend
effectively funnel people away from it
it would go either side
when this access takes them directly up
to it and
you end up on the main road which isn't
exactly the best route and that just
takes you down to the co-op in the
village
um or bypasses it all together
thank you very much anyone else for a
question counselor dixon please
uh luis um where abouts on our map into
the shop
sorry it's it's not um so it's um
yeah around where the cursor is there so
it's on on the right-hand side of
uh league president as you come down
from stockton road so it's
about halfway up from the main road at
the top down to the bottom
any further questions for cancer adam
please no
okay council adam thank you very much i
hope you continue to get a full night's
sleep
good luck right let's open two uh
questions
for our officers once clarification uh
cancer fielding had one first for our
solicitor so cancer fielding please
thank you mr chairman um
under common law when i was dealing with
land management we always used to make
sure that if the
route a road was being used by the
general public but it was a private
route
we made sure that the gate was locked at
least
once a year to stop ongoing traffic
therefore under common law um
is this a right of access that we
um can be taken into account
i think really that members need to
focus on condition 10
and ask themselves whether they still
think that condition is necessary
and relevant to planning and meets the
tests or planning conditions
um i wouldn't get too fixated on whether
it's a public right-of-way or not
that would that determination will be
made in another place you need to decide
whether that condition
you think is necessary um to this scheme
or not
thank you very much council mills thank
you mr chairman actually my um
my worries i i did visit the site and
did walk down to the
towpath and from the shop but the site
itself um
it's not it's not a very wide road
coming into that site is it um
can two vehicles couldn't pass
by each other could they joe
i'll be honest that was already debated
in the full applications that this is
solely on the basis of the access no
okay all right then
i'll shut up any other points
clarification
we've had a lot of these applications
where houses are being built in garage
sites and whatever
and we had one in my now my journey ward
um where it was access to a recreation
field
um and ultimately that was upheld
for exactly the same reason no public
right away
no sign up no whatever but just a uh
an access to a facility or an amenity
that had gone on for 30 plus years so
from that perspective
i i wouldn't like to see this
this this section 10 being deleted i
i think it should be kept as it is i
think that's moved us into the debates
does anyone else have a question of
points of clarification before we
carry on with the debates no okay does
anyone else want to chip in on the
debates
cancer jennings first please okay this
is all about condition 10 the legal
arguments about rights of way et cetera
they're for lawyers we're not lawyers um
parish are entitled to look at judicial
reviews
deal with a county um go pursue
the courts whatever that's completely
separate we're here to base
base our decision on material planning
matters which is the important thing
here
when we're not here to guess if people
are guests still going to use the shop
it's not relevant here this is all about
this is all about
condition 10. the office is satisfied
that the condition is no longer relevant
as there are two other access
to the canal i'm satisfied as well i'm
happy to propose that we go along with
the officer's decision
and grant this cancer kendall next
please
how's the council jennings you've said
everything i was thinking it's about
this entire case about the reasonability
of whether it's reasonable to insist
that there's another
access here the office has made a very
good case there are two other accesses
i'm happy to second your proposal thank
you very much councillor crump
yeah i'm sorry i must admit i'll totally
disagree with my two colleagues here
i'm afraid totally um
you might well have governed that i know
the area very well in fact i was born
just up the road
uh so i used to play football and
cricket in those garages
and if i hit it too hard it'd go over
the garages
and either go in the canal or on the
towpath
that road that path has been used for
donkeys years
um so i think you know it's
i get the point about viability i think
yeah it's about the communities
and the viability i know the shop i used
to know the owners of the shop i need to
know the owners before it as well
and before that as well so it is part of
their trade it
is part of their viability and if that
shop goes out of business
there's no other shop for about a mile
and a half down the main road
so we need to support local businesses
all about localism so i'm certainly
passionate about this
again it's public ground protect and
enhance the setting the emerging ndp
locus right away you say about the two
other accesses
well these accesses is not as close as
you think yeah
if you wanted to go to the blue lights
from from the shop or from where you
were
you'd have to walk 400 yards down in one
direction
go for flight of the steps then come
back 400 yards at the opposite direction
where you could just walk 100 yards down
through this axis and go towards the
blue lights
so that argument i don't think is
particularly valid
um and again public right away planning
laws
you know i don't know whether kent's the
general has actually visited the site or
knows it
because he certainly won't know as well
as i do so i think you know
i totally disagree and i'll propose that
we refuse this uh
removal of condition 10.
cancer fielding i must agree
with councillor crump um it is a very
difficult one
but on the fact that it's been used for
so long
it's actually it could actually be
argued that this
change is premature until we get
something from
the uh footpath um on county
but i i think it should really be
allowed to remain
and be kept so i will second councillor
crumple on this one
that's answer seraphin john could you
tell me michael chair
i agree with councillor crump it's it's
an important thing for
community and people to have this sort
of access
it's if it's been used since the 1950s
then they really have a right to use it
so i would
totally agree with cancer crop thank you
i'm just going to make one point on our
solicitor made this before we are not
here to determine
whether or not this is a public right of
access
that is not our responsibility that is
the responsibility
of the highways authority so please bear
that in mind when you're making your
decisions and thinking about this
council curtis please thank you um
bearing in mind the point you just made
the rights of way act 1922
where away upon or overland has actually
been enjoyed by the public
as of right and without interruption for
20 years
such way shall be deemed to have been
dedicated
a highway unless there is sufficient
evidence
that there was no encounter curtis i'm
going to stop you there that
is a pitch that should be put to the
county council when they're making a
decision as to whether this
is or is not a right of access we
are not here to determine that i will
just quote then from our policy
cs9 connected proposals will be well
integrated with existing built form
enhancing
the network of streets footpaths and
green infrastructure access
green infrastructure across the site and
the locality
and retaining existing rights of way
that is in our policy
i completely agree with councillor crumb
council dixon please
thank you chairman um i don't know where
the school is
and i certainly heard reference to
children going from the modeled village
to the school
um looking at the map and where the
model village is
and where the black dot is on the north
side of the canal
to my mind anybody going from modern
village uh through the garage
site must be getting fairly close to the
to the pub where the footpath is if
you'd like designated to come down to
the two boats
so i'm actually on the this side with
councillor jennings
um essentially um the two boats in 176
metres to the west
um now i don't know where the nearest
shop is going to be
um but councillor trump said if that one
was closed it's going to be one and a
half miles away
um so 176 metres
will cause the closure of a shop when
the next ones are one and a half miles
away
sorry i'm in favor of the recommendation
from the officers
okay thank you very much no one else has
indicated their desire to speak so we
will move
to a vote we have a proposal to grant in
line with the officer's recommendation
that has been seconded
we do also have a proposal to refuse and
that has been seconded
we will take the first one first
while we do that and in case that
doesn't
succeed please for the proposal and
secondary to refuse can you think about
your planning reasons as to why
you think we should refuse this so in
the first instance the vote is
to grant in line with officers
recommendation that was proposed by
councillor jennings seconded by
councillor kendall
could all those in favor please show
their hands now
four three four it's against
three four five six six so that fails
we therefore need to hear from cancer
crumb cancer filling for their planning
reasons as to why you think we should
refuse this please
um all right there's a couple of things
well
i would say i still maintain the point
about
uh supporting businesses to make sure
they're viable
especially uh if the nearest one is a
mile a mile and a half away
i'll totally disagree with totally
cancer dixon on that one
obviously maintaining public access uh
to protect and enhance uh the setting uh
mounting of the public realm
and the path was mentioned in the
emerging
ndp longest long edgington and obviously
um some form of localism as well um
whichever policies we can find yeah
obviously it's
been used by the public for a long while
uh
and this is something that the community
would want so
i think there are some various different
policies i think
um council curtis mentioned cs9
in some respect as well um so
i think there might be enough planning
reasons there will actually give me
the planning policy numbers
do you mind summarizing that and giving
us your professional view thank you very
much
yeah of course so um there are three
things i took from that and feel free to
correct me if
i'm wrong um the first point in terms of
supporting businesses in the local shop
my concern is that we don't have any
evidence that
whether this path is there or not that
it would have an impact on the shop and
i know
you believe that to be the case but i
think in the absence of evidence i think
it would be a tricky one to defend
appeal
in terms of defending it it would have
to be cs22 of the core strategy which is
uh economic development and i just don't
think
it's strong enough to be able to defend
however moving on to the next
point you made reference to um sort of
protection and enhancement
of the the path which i think comes back
to what councilor curtis suggested in
terms of 0.4
of cs 9 which is design and
distinctiveness and that's
the section council curtis quoted
proposals will be well integrated with
the existing built form enhancing the
network of streets footpaths and green
infrastructure across the site
and the locality and retaining existing
rights of way i think it's reasonable
um that that if members were minded to
uh refuse that we would go down that
route
and then i think the third point i
picked up on was the ndp
what i will say is that's in quite an
early stage it's in draft form so it
only has limited weight so again i'd
recommend steering away from that and
really just focusing on that cs9 point
are you happy with that i'm happy to go
there in that path
seriously that's the feeling you're
happy
i'm happy with that yes good i'm a great
believer in safety for kids walking to
school
okay on that basis we have a proposal
that's been seconded and we have a
reason for that proposals being put
forward so could we please all have
a show of hat you're happy with that
yeah can we please all have a show of
hands for those in favor of refusing
this application
one two three four five six and for
those against
for any abstentions zero therefore this
application application 21
0 0 561 vary um has been resolved to
refuse
by the planning committee as set out
okay we will move on to our final
application of the evening which is
application twenty zero three three zero
six ful and also uh twenty zero three
three zero seven
lbc the old butcher's shop in claverdon
uh we have stuart fleit as our
presenting officer
he will make himself comfortable in just
a second and we will get on with that
one
you ready
okay stewart over to you
right thank you chairman uh good evening
everybody um
this proposal seeking full planning
permission enlisted building consent for
the erection of a dwelling
the application site is within the
adopted build very boundary of claverden
as indicated by the black dots on this
plan
here we see a plan denoting the
application site
uh the black line indicates this
application boundary
uh one can see that we reside within the
conservation area as signified by the
purple line
uh there are then listed buildings in
both the immediate and wider facility
the application site is washed over by
the green belt and we're also in a
highly sensitive archaeological area
in addition to being within a designated
art and special landscape area
here we see the proposed site plan
showing the footing of the proposed
dwelling and the associated development
around it
here we see the proposed elevational
detail um
here where my if you can see my cursor
that's the main
proposed main frontage as viewed from
the highway
um the rear elevation is then shown at
the top
here and then with the side elevations
there
here we see an indicative imagery
provided by the applicant
which shows how the dwelling would sit
uh
in the wider area we now have some site
photos here we are still on the footpath
looking
north eastwards one can see this is a
vacant plot
um and that there are some structures
that have
previously been demolished through
previous planning permission
there is then a neighbouring property
here a further neighbouring property
here
here we are just a bit further away on
the opposite side of the highway
looking at where the dwelling would then
sit um
there's also then one can see here the
structure that's currently in situ
that's supposed to be demolished as part
of this proposal
and this is said structure looking um a
different direction southward
in its current state
finally here we just see a little
snapshot of some dwellings that are
immediately opposite the application
site
on the opposite side of the road um to
give us sort of a better sense of the
area we're in
identifiable harm has been ident it's
been identified by officers
to the significance of heritage assets
in the area uh the cumulative impact of
this development detrimental impact on
historic character
the introduction of this dwelling and
associated development is deemed to
result in incongruous edition that is
not sensitive to the wider area
harm is then also additionally
identified to the neighboring properties
owing to the scale and height of this
dwelling please refer chairman to the
update sheet for a clarification on a
neighbouring property
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
both these applications for the reasons
to set out on page 107 and 108 of your
genders thank you
sure thank you very much indeed um our
first speaker our only speaker on this
item
mr ellison do come on down
good evening welcome i think you know
the drill we've seen you here a few
times before so three minutes i'll give
you 30 second warning whenever you're
ready
feel free to start
good evening my name is steve elson i'm
a chartered architect at brock charles
and we are agent for this application
the existing shot was approved to be
extended in 2014
and interestingly on a larger footprint
than is presented before you today
you may remember that we met in 2019 to
discuss a dwelling
on this site by adding a first floor
extension
to the still redundant shop and that was
refused
thank you following the uh
dwelling refusal from two years ago the
applicant then continued to implement
the shop approval by demolishing the
unwanted flat roof connection
they believe this was now their only
option however the local parish council
now support a new home what is extremely
disappointing
is that these applications were
submitted in november last year
yes over seven months ago now and the
council planning officers decided not to
work with the applicant at all
the first we heard from the planning
officer this this year was when we were
notified of the planning committee
simply too late to do anything the 25
years i've worked with stratfor council
planners this has been a unique
experience
where the officer has chosen to avoid
working with an applicant
we were asked we asked for an extension
of time and this has been ignored
and removed any opportunity to stop
meeting with you tonight and wasting
your time
and for that i apologize
only either planning and conservation
office are objecting to this application
and with vague conclusions along with
some neighbors who still want to block
traffic along the narrow road and park
cars across the pavement
hopefully we've seen these photographs
submitted tonight
you can see why your highways department
does not object to this application
in fact no one else does of course the
shop extension approval also impacts on
these neighbors and this will of course
generate more
park traffic than someone's home the
proposed dwelling is only a two bedroom
home
with open plan living areas the ridge
height is less than 7.6 metres high
small for a house and is constructed to
the current building regulations
unlike the small neighboring houses from
200 years ago
the proposed home is surrounded by both
higher and lower dwellings
along the green and matches their
materials you can see this clearly in
our street scene drawings
this is a limited infill in the
greenbelt so as acceptable
there are larger houses within the
proximity of the listed dwelling
so there is no harm or dominance here to
a heritage asset
and some properties even have less
architectural merit
than this home the site remains a
derelict eyesore
we thought this proposal would be seen
favorably as a cottage star home with
victorian detailing to complement this
excuse me to complement the surrounding
conservation area
there is no overlooking or overbearing
due to the wind positioning
and its architectural form this is
uniquely frustrating that the planning
office has chosen to avoid working with
the applicants
we now look to yourselves to some common
sense from a planning committee and i
hope
or who sorry who i hope are shocked by
how the applicant has been treated and i
hope to avoid the need and cost
for a planning appeal thank you for your
time i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much steve um members do
we have any questions for mr ellison
please
no in that case mr erson thank you very
much indeed if you give the table a
quick wipe and we will carry on
plus clarification for the offices does
anyone have a point of clarification
councilman mel
thanks very much indeed um stuart um
what is the the the total height of that
uh of the new proposed uh
building opposed to the old bushes shop
how much higher is it
uh thank you uh councillor uh the old
butcher shop
shown here is 5.6 meters to the ridge
uh we have measured this proposed
dwelling to be 7.6 meters to the ridge
uh an approximate two meter increase
thank you thank you mr curtis thank you
just following him from council mills um
are there do you have ridge heights of
other
company other buildings along the street
because we've heard
that this isn't overly dominant compared
to other buildings so can you give us an
idea of how it compares to other
ridge heights of buildings um i can and
i can't
there is a helpful imagery provided by
the applicant and the agent
which gives an indicative view on how
this house would sit
uh i would hasten to add you can't scale
off on a plan such as this
i don't have any other detailed
measurements i could give you as part of
this application for the other dwellings
i can if you wish uh i've got showed you
one photo
of the surrounding area um there are a
few others if it would
if it would help your view at all um to
show
other neighboring that's on the opposite
side correct yes
um so we have
other dwellings on the same road
here that's looking towards the village
that's the
uh cleveland court but if i go back to
the old butcher's shop itself um
where are we well we can't actually
there's no photo but this plan
is scaled off and it's exactly the
correct measurements but i don't have
any other detailed ridge heights to give
you for the surrounding properties i'm
afraid
okay cancer feeling
you seem to indicate when we were
getting
a briefing earlier on that the
as planning officers you weren't in
principle
against this development is that correct
is it the conservation officer
who is the main one who is holding it
back
thank you uh councillor um to answer
your first question
we have found the prince from this
development to be acceptable um i've
detailed about the gender pac we've also
found it to be acceptable developing the
green belt
uh in terms of matters of in-field
development um
as is detailed in the proposed reasons
for refusal we have found other areas of
concern
and we've proposed reasons for refusal
which relate to crudely
napping amenity uh the character street
scene design
element as a second strand and the third
strand definitely
as is proposed by in-house conservation
officer
uh who objected to both these
applications is on matters of heritage
as well
but no i wouldn't agree that it's solely
the conservation officer has driven us
to this conclusion
um we've uh on a unified front i found
other areas
for objection as well casa dixon
stuart am i right to believe that you
haven't got a photograph of the old
butcher's
shop uh to show us because isn't that
the one listed building that's going to
be the closest to us
and which ought to be given some sort of
significance in our deliberations
because if we haven't that's it and the
relationship
to that to the proposed new building is
a space of two meters that's it is that
the
is was that the face that would be
facing the new building
that gabriel end uh thank you council i
can
elaborate that's the frontage as we're
looking at you can see a snapshot here
in the background there
that's going to where my cursor is
that's going to be part of the new
dwelling
um there is a separation distance of
three and a half meters
from this old butcher shop grades who
listed uh to this proposed new dwelling
below this
the next photo down uh yep
this is uh facing the road this side as
well
that's me stood on the road taking a
photo
that's not facing though does it uh no
big department sorry correct sorry i'll
correct myself i'm standing on the road
here apologies
that's facing uh where this proposed
dwelling is
apologies
if you could put your microphone on so
that that is coming down
if that's if that's facing where the
dwelling's going that's presumably being
demolished
that dwelling is staying the old picture
shot there the actual
dwelling that's occurring in situ is
staying there and it's my understanding
it's also occupied at this very moment
um and that elevation as you see it is
approximately three and a half meters
to where the proposed dwelling is going
i am struggling would you like us to
think we should have
an adjournment until a future date but
would you like to have a map brought up
an aerial bird's eye view so you can see
would that be better
would you mind doing that for us so the
location panel the block plan or
something like that please
yeah so yes this is the
dwelling that's currently in situ called
the old butcher shop
it's grade two listed there is a
proposal for a new dwelling here
which then there is a separation there
of approximately three and a half meters
are you are you happy you understand now
cancer dixon yeah i can see the
relationship between the two i'm not
sure if the old butcher shop is that
superb thank you very much um do we have
any other questions
no let's move into the debate who would
like to kick us off cancel the mills sir
yes thanks michelle yes i looked at this
um
on sunday i think yeah um
yes it is an iso next door but i am
concerned though looking at that
how it it is overbearing to the old
butcher shop
i mean something's got to be done there
but uh
it does seem rather large you know and
it for me it doesn't fit in with
with the street scene there so um i
i would go on the officer's
recommendation on this one at the moment
thank you
at the moment is that a formal proposal
yes i think so mr chairman thank you
very much uh councillor jennings you're
indicated next please
yeah and the the principle of building
something that
i totally agree with um my only issue
here would be the size and scale of the
proposal
um but definitely something needs to be
done on this site
so i'm happy to second okay
thank you very much cancer fielding
having seen the photographs of the other
houses in the area
i would have thought that this is not as
overbearing as it
looks in these federal in these plans
um i'm happy to go along with it the
parish
is happy with it um and it is
it's been around and it's been something
that's been
um on the books for some some years
i remember seeing the one in in 20
in 2018 um i propose that
we accept we will go against the
officer's
uh refusal and off and go for grant was
that a former proposal sorry i missed
yes yeah
okay thank you very much council curtis
and thank you
i would find it given that the the um
suggestions for refusal are
new build comparative to listed
buildings it doesn't
it harms a setting the conservation area
it's a prominent
an incongruous edition i think it would
be i would certainly have found it more
helpful
to have more photographs of the street
scene
so we can get comparisons of the wider
area rather than just comparisons with
that one
particular building just for future
reference really
okay if i mean what we could say is you
do have
the ability to uh propose a deferment so
that you can go on a site visit and see
the site and see the wider area
i'm not encouraging you to do that
necessarily um that is within your
gift i'll just remind you that that is
within your gift
does anyone else want to speak in the
debate before we go anywhere else
council dixon uh taking
taking well that wasn't a prompt but i
i'm not familiar with the site i would
like to become familiar with the site so
i would
actually propose a deferment of the
decision
so that a site visit can be made by
those members
who are not familiar with the site i
don't know if that will be seconded
counselor curtis i would like to second
that proposal
okay absolutely not absolutely not hang
on we will vote on that at an
appropriate time
we're still within the debate we have
now have two propos
sorry we have three proposals two of
which have been seconded
and just to confuse everyone i'm going
to second the other one
because i agree with cancer fielding i
don't have any particular issue with
this i do think this fits in with the
street scene i don't believe that it has
a
significantly detrimental effect on the
historic building in the grade 2 listed
buildings in the vicinities
so i have no problem with this but
obviously we as a group
are here to make a decision as a
collective so
the first proposal by councillor mills
and council
secretary by council jennings is to
refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation we will take that first
could i please have a show of hands for
those in favor of refusal
three and those against
one two three four five six any
abstentions
one okay so that fails our second
proposal is to defer so that members can
go on a site visit and understand the
locality
um but the other things that we said
proposed by council dixon seconded by
cancer curtis
could we please have a show of hands for
those in favor of a site visit
three those against
also three abstentions
three three i get the casting on this
one missing
four so i have four extensions i get the
casting vote
wonderful
[Laughter]
hang on a second let me just get some
really good
oh
it's fun isn't it so
in the interests of fairness
um and to ensure that we all are making
a decision with all the facts
i am going to say yes we will go on a
site visit
um i think that is the fairest thing to
do particularly given the planning
history of this site
and the frustrations that were expressed
by our agent
so we will do that and we will return
and make a decision
fully informed having visited the site
and that applies to both the full
application and the lbc
okay sadly we do have to vote on the lbc
separately
so i'm going to assume council addiction
that your proposal is still stands to
for the lbc and yourself seconding
council curtis
fabulous can we please have a show of
hands those in support of going
on site visit for the lvc part that is
unanimous
marvelous so we will do that so that
item will be deferred
members there is no urgent business
other than the fact the football kicked
off ten minutes ago so
i'll close the meeting thank you very
much indeed thank you chairman
you